[Musique]
des mouvements envoûtant presque
hypnotique la chorégraphe américaine
lucinda childs en a fait sa marque de
fabrique au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
le ballet de l'opéra de lyon
interprétera sa pièce maîtresse dance un
chef-d'oeuvre de la danse contemporaine
à la ses mouvements à elle que
généralement quelle qu'elle aime bien
utiliser des soutenu des temps lever
enfin voilà beaucoup de changements de
direction de diagonale de ligne de
départ de personnes à des endroits
différents mais doivent le un timing
tout à fait ensemble la bande-son
derrière et pas forcément très rythmé ma
lauriane tel travail que les départs des
danseurs sont impeccablement en même
temps
créée en 1979 dance est devenu une pièce
intemporelle la musique lancinante signé
philip glass ensorcelle le spectateur un
dispositif filmique laisse entrevoir les
reflets des danseurs sur la scène
aucun faux pas n'est tolérée le ballet
est réglé au millimètre on n'y avait pas
travailler beaucoup à la gamme comme sur
l'autre vesakh scène avec la bey'a
allait on n'est pas tout à fait en même
temps donc on a beaucoup travaillé sur
ça sur scène et c'est vrai que ça change
franchement
exceptionnel de danser les pièces que
j'appréciais beaucoup que j'étudie
une histoire derrière le ballet de
l'opéra de lyon est la seule compagnie à
avoir refait le film avec ses danseurs
dance est constitué de trois parties de
20 minutes sans entracte une heure de
mouvements de sauts et de grâce féerique
un voyage entre rêve et réalité